افاد مراسل الجزيره انها جنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ترافقهم جرافات الهدم اقتحموا
قريه دير عمار غرب مدينه رام الله في
الضفه الغربيه وشرعوا في هدم منزل يعود
لمواطن فلسطيني بحجه عدم حصوله على ترخيص
للبناء
معنى الان مبنى رام الله مراسله الجزيره
جيفارا البوديري لتوافينا بمجمل هذه
التطورات والتفاصيل اليك جيفارا
ازدهار كانت قواتها الاحتلال قد نفذت
العديد من عمليات
الاقتحام والاعتقالات في عدد من القرى
والبلدات في الضفه الغربيه او ساعتها كان
في جنين اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال هناك خمسه
فلسطينيين ايضا كان هناك مواجهات نوعا ما
محدوده في منطقه
قلقيليه ولكن اوسع المواجهات كانت فجر هذا
اليوم ولكنها بدات في ساعات متاخره من
مساء الليله الماضيه عندما اقتحمت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المنطقه الشرقيه
لمدينه نابلس ومخيم بلاطه حيث يوجد قبر
يوسف الذي يزعم الاحتلال والمستوطنين
المستوطنين بانه مكان ديني لليهود قوات
الاحتلال اقتحمت المنطقه لتامين حمايه
دخول المجموعات من المستوطنين اندلعت
اشتباكات مسلحه بين مقاومين فلسطينيين
وجنود الاحتلال وايضا بين شبان فلسطينيين
استخدموا الحجاره لمواجهه قوات الاحتلال
وفق الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني سجلت اصابتان
بالرصاصه الحي وعشرات الاصابات بحالات
اختناق تم علاج ميدانيا ولكن ايضا كان
هناك توتر وهو بالطبع متواصل منذ اكثر من
شهر في داخل السجون الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
واستعداد الاسرى للدخول في الاضراب مع
الاول من رمضان الاسبوع القادم ان لم
تتراجع سلطات الاحتلال عن كل العقوبات
الجماعيه بحق الاسرى وفق نادي الاسير
الفلسطيني كان هناك اقتحام لقسم ثلاثه في
السجن نفحى ذلك على المستوى الميداني
ازدهار ولكن ايضا هناك خلف الكواليس على
المستوى السياسي الممثل الخاص للشؤون
الامريكيه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه هذه عامر
التقى بالامس مع امين سر اللجنه التنفيذيه
لمنظمه التحرير حسين الشيخ وبعد ذلك مع
رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني محمد شتيه كل ذلك
لتحضير للاجتماع او لقاء القمه في شرم
الشيخ المصريه والمجماع عقدها يوم الاحد
القادم وفق حركه فتح فان الشيخ سيتراس وفد
فلسطين الى هذه القمه نذكر ان هذه القمه
هي استكمال لقمه العقبه في الاردن الشهر
الماضي والتي كانت تهدف لوقف التصعيد في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه هي قمه خماسيه وفد
فلسطيني اخر اسرائيلي ولكن برعايه
رسميه من الاداره الامريكيه وبمشاركه
المخابرات الاردنيه والمصريه كل ذلك يهدف
بالطبع لوقف التصعيد قبيله شهر رمضان
المبارك من رام الله مراسله الجزيره
جيفارا البوديري شكرا جزيلا لك